ah haha guten tag ah that's morning
we're going to play busy oculus I find
some very nice game for us and we're
going to check them out let's go
[Music]
all right here we go Bruce oh my god
what happened to my computer I need my
computer
alright warning tsunami island playing
welcome to tsunami island
okay you'll begin the tutorial alright
let's start by moving with the W a s and
D Keys what Asha Sonam is coming breath
what the [ __ ] Oh God I'm scared I'm
scared present scared all right well I
guess we we run no problem this is a lot
less exciting than I thought it would be
okay why would I run to another side of
the shore that's a terrible idea
maybe if we can get up on this building
we'll be okay maybe get in the boat
Oh sea level is rising quake Oh God
let's chop these boxes up [ __ ] Yvonne
says you can't tell me what to do and I
died best game ever would never [ __ ]
play that piece of [ __ ] again what the
[ __ ] waste my [ __ ] time
[Music]
all right this game is called back to
the future
it's the prey day it's a game about
going back to the future again once this
car hits 88 miles per hour
oh god I'm pretty sure we're not
supposed to go backwards I don't know
how the future works okay well I did
need the door to be open please close
okay here we go damn it
this car can fly apparently that's cool
no big deal I'm pretty sure this is how
it worked in the real there we go the
close the door god damn it god damn it I
need to hit 88 we're [ __ ] flying
still it's like a cat no it's an island
okay
thought it was a cat all right all right
all right video games brothers video
games Wow
[Music]
all right this next one is a horror game
so it that means it has to be a good
game am i right ladies
you ladies know what I'm talking about
aren't you
am I wearing high heels oh [ __ ] me that
looks scary as [ __ ] but find a key oh oh
it's my jam
it's my own all right all right all
right can I see Makani oh there you up
got a target you some house
buried in a bit zip it miss it
Oh someone's playing the piano that's so
nice hello there hello there piano
player you play a lovely song a lovely
something find a safe room key no
problem I'll just ask the pianist where
it is okay that's a little scary
Oh God hello oh god it's so dark
oh my god this is [ __ ] legitimately
terrifying hello oh [ __ ] me man I forgot
how scary it is with your lace Oh [ __ ]
sake Jesus Christ this is scary oh [ __ ]
my house out why am I going in here okay
okay
price
what's that sound I hear a sound and I
don't like it gonna hug the wall now oh
oh god I'm gonna die here I'm good at it
hey oh it's just a find it was just a
fan all right
it's just hubris hey get it cuz I said
fan whoa what's goin on what's goin on
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty [ __ ] oh my god I
pledged it huh goose bumps all over my
tits which implies I have hairy toes
which is okay [ __ ] no man okay don't
want to be here never and I read alright
I'm Matthew McConaughey just gonna keep
paddling through here why I don't know I
just want to grab a bag of Cheetos and
stick them up my ass that's what I
rather do this weekend yeah enough birds
can open doors everyone knows that of
course there's someone sitting there
Oh God hello I use the pianist
okay this ladder then huh all right what
do we got here you look like yeah you
don't look too good man oh there's the
key all right yeah I guess you guys
don't want me to leave huh oh [ __ ]
that's the Oh God
oh [ __ ] I got some Cheetos that I need
to stick up my ass done I'm gonna go
spits been great though thoroughly enjoy
my dad
let's play something nice yeah how about
that
birdie burger yes hey what the [ __ ] oh
[Music]
of course
what are you doing mate mm-hm
yes that's funny boof
[Applause]
I don't like this can we just get it on
the burger burning oh my god this is
[ __ ] amazing
oh my god oh god this can't be it does
I can't
oh my dog oh my god a lot of motion
sickness that's the best no really I
love it oh my god
all right brother Sui got finished off
with what we really want oculus rift for
anyway there it is
yes oh god that's nice
[Music]
all right thank you for watching this
video leave a comment about my Kumiko's
ass and I will see you in the next one
stay awesome bros you feelin can you
fail it's like the space is coming
through my fingertips
[Music]